now the socks go for the double headers
sweep against the baltimore orioles and
on the mound for the socks lance lynn
last time out seven innings that would
be a complete game today in a seven
inning double headers
on the ground timid shorts got to hustle
it and a nice play smoothly done by tim
anderson on the exchange and pick for
round number one and this is much more
difficult than it looked because of this
hop you got to carry the glove as low as
you possibly can because you can come up
on any hop
they'll drive you absolutely crazy is
juwan moncada takes it to first two down
[Applause]
in the air to right
not near the foliage
danny mendick makes the catch no score
after a half inning john means trying to
run his record to 5-0 low era 38 hits 65
and third innings incredible almost a
strikeout per inning
there's a hook in there for strike three
it took a while chance cisco filters it
back down into the strike zone behind
the plate watch him pull it down a
little bit
nicely done ball four on the changeup
and yaz takes a walk from the two spot
bottom of the first no score the pitch
breaking ball in and they say monkato
went around monkata
holding his hands
even as he goes back to the dugout just
to
show edwin moscoso how little he
actually
had moved his hands
that hits him jose is going to first
and now the sox will have two on so it's
been strikeout walk strikeout hit batter
that's ball four a change up out of the
zone and the sox have loaded the bases
without a hit
3-0 green lightning he popped it up
better gets him oh boy stewart should be
stuart
oh that was shaky that was shaky but
it's caught that's the big thing
white sox leave them loaded we go to the
second no score
lancelin ready two balls no strikes
breaking ball sashayed into right field
a little spin on that one one on one
down for the orioles
struck him out lance holds the finish
you look like steph curry inning over
1-2 pitch hamilton late and he's a
strikeout victim
[Applause]
mendic high fly a ball deep right field
sondheim dare on the track
and or that steward out there in right
field makes the catch
white sox down in order in the second
strike three it's a four-seamer and it's
the second strikeout for lance lynn he
locked up mckenna
here's tim at shortstop
for out number three jose even had a
little struggle trying to find that ball
but now he's off to the races they might
be calling catchers interference
it was a ground ball to anderson the
inning was
all but over the white sox left the
field of play
and now it appears home play umpire
edwin ruscoso has called catcher's
interference
and mullins will reach
off the sixth catcher's interference
against the sox this year
a wave and a missed strike three and now
lance
will dance off the mound
no problem
hey tim provides a spark into center
field and he'll take a lead off singled
monkana to center field
two one that was uh nearly a disastrous
personal for john means on the mound
johann mon monkatta's own walk-up song
two on one down no score third inning
one-two pitch oh beauty and he didn't
have to he went for the curveball
this is what brandon hyde talked about
the fact that maybe you don't have the
best change up tonight so you have a
curveball you can go to
maybe against the lefty you have a
slider and here's the hook
major league pop up here
who's got it wilkerson
makes the catch so the sox strand two
they're retired in the third still no
score game two in chicago
oh and two from lancelin
and stuart swings through a cutter
lancelin has got it all together he gave
up just one single and that just drops
out of the zone
franco will need a new bat next time he
approaches the plate okada across the
diamond and that will do it
hamilton
with two down
hamilton to left mckenna back at the
wall it is gone
billy hamilton turns on a pitch that was
down the middle
for the first run of today's game
well billy hamilton has been a
revelation for our socks
did you say going home
go home wilkerson go home
he's got eight outs to find in this
seven inning game
that's one of them
sinker to the corner mount castle could
only hope moscosa didn't ring him up
well look you saw high fastballs then
you saw a couple of cutters and now you
see a sinker that actually dives back
over the plate
[Applause]
right field hit pretty well
mendic on the run won't get there oh
tough oh there you go ground
top
definitely had a run there cisco would
have scored
jogging in
he's tried to heat him upstairs a couple
of times one two
three
lynn takes mullins down
i think lance thought he had the upper
hand the whole way
both pitchers have given up exactly
three hit
monkatta at a short over galvez sort of
over him and around him yeah i meant
four hits
so jose gets to bat with a runner on
here in the fifth
jose lights it up yes he did wait back
and bring him home
that ball was destructed
for a three-nothing lead
jose is one of the smartest hitters
around
full count pitch to galvez
missed inside and the orioles got a lead
off base runner
line drive base hit
so the orioles with the first two on
here in the sixth inning
down low ball four and they're loaded
that probably was a strike
they cannot be happy one 1-1 to franco
into center field hamilton comes in and
billy ties to make the play billy
hamilton just saved the shutout and
galvez didn't read it so one down and
the billy hamilton cheering section
grows
by a multiplier
[Applause]
oh hillary caught him yep there's a run
take one for the rbi got it on the elbow
look like
so now galvest gets to score tying runs
now
well
go ahead run it first
dying run now at second one two coming
from hoyer
there it is a little half swing monkatta
at third takes his time
and ships it over for round number three
jose anchored himself to the bag and the
inning's over leo hendrix comes into the
game looking for his 12th save and 14
attempts
farewell to
young ryan mckenna
two and two here we go fastball the
invisible fastball two down
he just goes 98
and throws it right by him for two up
two down
two and two
he struck him out
hendricks again blitzes the orioles
striking out the side to save in each
game the sox win a doubleheader today
white sox three
orioles one